just as shigaraki is about to activate
his awakened Decay and literally
disintegrate all the heroes and hero
students at UA a fan favorite character
returns from the dead to save the day
the only problem is this character used
to be a villain in fact multiple
villains from the past have returned and
are now siding with the heroes but can
they be trusted all the important pieces
have been placed on the board just as
the final showdown between full power
shigaraki and Deku is about to begin and
the whole world seems to be blowing up
all around them so let's get into it you
guys know how this works if you enjoy
rmha vids and you want us to keep it
going just leave a quick like and
comment it only takes you a second but
it really helps me out a lot and just a
reminder that well over 50 percent of
people who watch our videos are not
subscribed this means that you're likely
missing a lot of our videos because
YouTube doesn't recommend them to you so
please do me a very quick favor and
subscribe right now it is completely
free and it really helps the channel
finally this video will of course
contain Boku hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned the previous chapter made it
clear that all the heroes and hero
students on the UA Battlefield are in
serious trouble shigaraki can now use
his quirks again and he also seems to be
in full control of his own body Sad
Man's parade is still a threat deck who
is running out of stamina and he is
struggling just to keep breathing and if
that wasn't bad enough the UA itself is
about to crash to the ground after its
flotation system was compromised but the
heroes still have hope because for
whatever reason all for one is still
unable to complete his takeover of
shigaraki's body this internal conflict
within shigaraki could be used by the
heroes to their advantage and also La
Brava managed to hack into skeptic
systems and she is now doing her best to
save everyone at UA from crashing to
their deaths we also learned of a secret
connection between one for all and all
for one the vestiges within one for all
can sense the inner workings of all for
one and they can tell that all for one
is having serious problems keeping the
separate identities within shigaraki
unified however on the flip side this
means that all for one also likely has
insight into the inner workings of one
for all and he may be able to sense what
the vestiges are thinking or feeling
this is a plot point that could become
important in the future so we'll have to
pay close attention the latest chapter
reveals that this is not the first time
that La Brava clashed with skeptic back
when she was just a nerdy shut-in she
actually hacked into Skeptics company
which is called Feel Good Inc that name
is actually a reference to a popular
song by the band gorillas La Brava
openly confesses to skeptic that she had
hacked him before and and he is shocked
to find out that it was her it seems
that he was kind of traumatized by that
previous hacking experience and that
incident caused him a lot of money
skeptic realizes that La Brava is
quickly gaining control of everything
and he seems to be unable to stop her at
this point he's just hoping that he can
keep her from Gaining access to the UA
evacuation system and that is something
that is clearly important to skeptic
because he has mentioned that system
multiple times we also know that the
villains have several spies among the
civilians who had been evacuated to the
UA so something is definitely Brewing
there now that La Brava has found him
skeptic plans to just run away and hide
somewhere while the villain Revolution
that he believes in so passionately
takes its course after all the floating
UA building is currently in free fall
and the priority of the heroes has to be
saving all the heroes and hero students
who are trapped there little does
skeptic know that his location is
already compromised and several Heroes
and hero students are already on his
Trail for her part labrava is trying her
best to gain access to the floating UA
system in order to stop the building
from falling but despite her best
efforts she just doesn't have enough
time she's obviously a great hacker but
the building will fall to the ground
before she has a chance to repair and
reboot the system meanwhile on the
floating UA itself Deku and shigaraki
are facing off against each other as the
ground beneath them begins to plunge
rapidly things look really bad over
there and the heroes and hero students
who have been maintaining the system are
now bracing for impact it just doesn't
seem like the heroes will be able to
save the UA in time and that is when a
villain comes to the rescue well a
former villain anyway the gentle
criminal has returned to the story and
unsurprisingly La Brava is Overjoyed
gentle has arrived to the spot where the
floating UA building is about to fall
and that's when we learn what he's been
up to all this time after being
apprehended by the authorities way back
in chapter 183 gentle had been
incarcerated inside one of the prisons
that all for one decided to break into
in order to free all the captives and
create chaos in the country and so about
a month and a half before these current
events gentle was one of the criminals
who was forcibly freed from mikuzu
prison right after Tartarus was attacked
it seems that muscular personally
spearheaded this specific breakout the
criminals and villains who had been
imprisoned there couldn't believe their
luck and they were already on their way
to get revenge against everyone who
wronged them before they ended up in
prison but before they had a chance to
escape the very hairy and disheveled
looking gentle used this Quirk to stop
the prisoners from running away thanks
to Gentle out of the seven different
prisons at which all for one had
orchestrated a jailbreak only this one
didn't actually have any skps that's
because gentle was there to stop them
all from escaping but why would gentle
do this when he himself was imprisoned
for being a villain well we all know
that gentle wasn't exactly a committed
villain he initially wanted to be a hero
and although he eventually turned to
Crime he was always more of a
fame-seeking gentleman criminal than an
actually dangerous villain and it seems
that the words that were spoken to him
by that gorilla investigator upon his
arrest really spoke to him the
investigator told him that people who
say that they can't turn their lives
around are just impatient and their lack
of commitment shows that they never had
a real desire to change in the first
place this combined with how
inspirational gentle found Deku to be
and also coupled with the fact that his
time away from La Brava made him realize
that he was in love with her and he
desperately wanted to be with her again
contributed to gentle's complete
turnaround from villain to hero and so
with labrava's love giving him Extra
Strength gentle decides to use his Quirk
to stop the UA building from from
crashing to the ground gentle manages to
create a giant air trampoline that
prevents the UA's fall and saves the
lives of everyone inside the building at
least for the time being I'm not sure
how long gentle can keep this kind of
thing up and frankly I'm surprised that
his Quirk is this strong even with LA
brava's quirk's support this seems like
a freaking Monumental task so I don't
know exactly how I feel about gentle's
Quirk being this overpowered what do you
guys think did horikoshi go too far by
making gentle's Quirk this strong or do
you like the fact that gentle is finally
getting some love let me know down below
either way there's no time to celebrate
because shigaraki is already making his
move now that he can use his quirks
again shigaraki tries to touch the
ground and activate Decay if he succeeds
then gentle's heroic effort will mean
nothing because everyone at the UA will
be destroyed anyway but just before the
K can activate shigaraki's right hand is
suddenly shot off with what looks like a
high-powered rifle and the oversized
bullet that did the damage seems quite
familiar the final page of the chapter
reveals that lady Nagant has returned
and she is the one who shot off
shigaraki's hand from a long distance
using her epic rifle Quirk oh and by the
way I wouldn't worry too much about
shigaraki's hand because he should now
be able to use super regeneration now
lady Nagant is clearly still injured she
is covered in bandages but her condition
has improved greatly and she is now back
in action and just like gentle and
labrava this time she is fighting on the
side of the heroes those of you who
watch this channel regularly know that
lady Nagant and miruko are like the top
two waifus in mha as far as I'm
concerned so you better believe that I'm
excited to see her again although at the
same time I am worried about what
horikoshi has planned for my girl in the
future because if you haven't noticed he
keeps injuring my waifus over and and
over again and I don't know how much
more of that I can take what are your
thoughts about all of these villains
coming back to the story and siding with
the heroes are we about to see something
similar from stain I've been waiting for
that for a very very long time oh and
how did lady nagan survive that
explosion in the first place we were led
to believe that all for one somehow
detonated an explosive inside of her
which would be extremely hard to survive
does Lady Nagant have other secret
quirks powers or abilities that we still
don't know about what role do you expect
her to play in this final battle can you
ever forgive me for being such a massive
lady Nagant simp let me know down in the
comments personally I think that having
all of these important characters from
the past returning for the final battle
is a big deal horikoshi is intentionally
putting all the pieces into place and
setting the stage for the Epic final
showdown between Deku and shigaraki this
is an all-out war and we can expect
heavy fighting and heavy casualties
especially now that shikiraki can use
his quirks again because let's be real
we haven't even seen shigaraki at full
power yet we have no idea what this guy
is truly capable of when all his quirks
are functioning I believe that the
hero's biggest Advantage right now is
the fact that shigaraki is still
undergoing a fierce internal struggle
and the personalities inside of him are
clearly not unified if the heroes can
use this to their advantage maybe they
can gain the upper hand over shigaraki
at a crucial point in the battle however
we can't forget deku's situation either
he is exhausted and worn out the very
cells of his body are overworked and he
is struggling to even breathe without
some major power up like for example one
for all attaining Quirk Singularity and
mutating into an even more powerful
super Quirk I don't think that Deku will
be able to pull off a win against
shigaraki nonetheless undergo some sort
of mental collapse as a result of his
internal struggle what are your thoughts
on what's going to happen next and how
do you think that mha will end don't
forget to leave your feedback below I
always love hearing from you if you're
looking for mha videos to watch next
check out our extensive playlist just
click the link right on the screen or in
the description below